hello everyone and welcome to round two
of the magnus carlsen invitational
tournament and it's everyone's favorite
matchup Magnus Carlsen versus Alvarez of
Fallujah after beating Magnus Carlsen
twice first and unleashes in bullet and
then in the Bandra blitz Cup in the
finals now is Carlson's the opportunity
to gain revenge in a in a slightly
longer time format these are rapid games
but yeah definitely a most welcome
opportunity for him so let's see let's
see how the game went and well we're
probably gonna cover more games but this
is only game one and also I would just
like to mention Jelena is holding a
tournament and leeches for sub 1,700
players so if you were sub 1,700 player
and you wish to join the link will be
the first thing you see in the
description below it starts 1900 Central
European Time so that being said let's
check out the game Magnus
for this opportunity opens with a d4
same as he did in the Bandra blitz Cup
we have Knight to f6 c4 e6 Knight f3 b5
and now Knight to c3
we have Bishop to b4 there are goes in
defences on the board and see characters
on d5 with he captures and again Magnus
goes for this Bishop to f4 idea and
while most usual moves here are our
castles in 94 Alireza goes for this move
that was almost never played
now there is one game with where it was
played in a classical game and it's
really weird since you block off your
your C pawn but it is it is a kind of a
novelty and the Magnus will have to do
something about it so here Magnus goes
rook to c1 and like I said there is one
game where castles played but here we
have just Knight to e4 and it is already
as of move 7 that we have a completely
new game and here since the rook is
already nicely guarding the night you
don't have to worry about that
Magnus goes a knight to be 2 and both
Magnus and fuchsia obviously know know
their way around the knight to c6 line
since here you are offering your d4 pawn
but you don't really gain anything by
capturing it because then Knight
captures and after pawn captures you
have the shrub characters on c7
if Queen captures then you just grab the
night here
so after night to be too we have g5 by
Allah race and before this g5 move
otherwise I did spend some three and a
half minutes on the move and prior to
that both of them I moved almost
instantly so here he was either trying
to remember what he had prepared or just
or maybe the night that he to move came
as a surprise and he was just checking
if g5 is a move and the Indian he did
play g5 now the point is if you move the
bishop to g3 then the knight just
captures and after captures now you can
capture the point so Magnus goes to the
e3 which looks ugly as how will you move
this pawn how will you develop your
pieces but ali reza sorry but Magnus
knows what he's doing is he moved it and
moved it pretty much instantly and here
there are some incredibly tricky lines
with f5 battle algorithm now refrains
from it instead he just trades on c3 we
have pawn characters and now Bishop to
e3 attacking the rook and the rook to be
one and only now f5 threatening f4 at
the trap cousins bishop so here g3
keeping control of the LDF Foursquare
also preparing to finger to the light
square bishop we have castles and now
Queen to b3 pushing the bishop back with
Bishop back to e7 and now as you can see
Carson's King is still in the center of
the board where as a lyricist King is
safely castle on the King side but he's
definitely feeling the draft here and as
Carson doesn't want to allow f4 he
pushes F for himself and okay Knight to
a5 attacking the Queen are probably
probably gonna shift the night over to
c4 at some point Queen to c2 end now c6
strengthening in the center and finally
Bishop to g2
we have Bishop to d6 now shifting the
bishop over turn I help out with with
this tension on the f4 square and now
Magnus goes c4 his king is still in the
center of the board but he's not at all
worried he does have a pawn in the
bishop in front of the team so the King
is
save here we have G captures on f4 and
now Magnus doesn't go for the show
characters he he likes the bishop here
and he goes for a G captures on f4 and
now he gets more control of the e5
square so you black will not be able to
exploit the e-file since you are
planning to move this knife from f3 to
e5 and then close of the e-file so brush
up the e6 by Allah Reza and now see
captors on d5 we have C captures and now
Magnus castles with both players now
with with no pawns on the G file so King
h8 by ali riza now the King will be
somewhat safer there and also you are
clearing the path for the rook stalk by
the G file we have Knight to f3 now
continuing with the 95 idea and now
since the night no longer covers see for
now holidays activates the night with
the Knight to c4 attacking the bishop
here so Queen to d3 defending and now at
b6 as the b7 pawn was a target here we
have kinked h1 by Magnus he also clears
the G file for his rooks sometimes in
the future and Queen to e7 now
developing the Queen connecting rooks
and putting putting in direct pressure
to the bishop err on e3 so nice the e5
by Magnus and here Alireza decides that
the monster night simply has to go and
since the dark square bishop doesn't
really have all that many all that many
diagonals to use he decides to give give
up the bishop pair so Bishop captures on
e5 we have F captures and only now rook
to g8
now with ideas of rook to g6 followed by
bringing the other rook over to g8
we have Bishop to f4 a really important
move as in some lines it allows the
Queen for you to ship the Queen over to
the King side but also it just keeps an
eye on the night here and also it
doesn't allow white to start pushing the
F pawn so it's a really a multi-purpose
move and also you are helping with with
the defense of the Kings side so rook
the g6 earlier Isaac continues with his
plan to double up on the G file and now
Bishop to h3 now across and doesn't
allow a razor to just double up here
because there's there's the problem of
the f5 pawn which Carlson is now
attacking twice
so rook the f8 by Allah Reza and now
rook the f3 preparing to bring this
recover to f1 and then create even more
threats against the f5 pawn and it is
questionable whether authorizer will be
able to defend it so Queen to h4 by a
Larissa now he wants to bring the the
Queen over to h5 to use for attacking
purposes but also the Queen from h5 will
be guarding f5 once again so rogue beat
the f1 bringing more firepower not to
the file and now Queen to h5 but now the
ship the c1 again nicely controlling
this Knight but also now there's no
defending the f5 bond for example you
could just keep it there and try and the
trade of some material and play this
endgame upon down for example b5 and
then everything gets traded off captures
captures captures captures captures
captures captures and captures and you
are playing the same game upon down with
cousin having a past epon which of
course Ali Reza doesn't doesn't enjoy
he's his lower on time so instead a
Larissa switches switches into a counter
attacking mode and now if this look for
example ever moves you have worked the
g1 checkmate which is always very nice
so Carson says ok now it's time to go
after the pawn bishop captures on f5 he
wins the pawn but now looked g2 by Allah
raised and now threatening checkmate on
h2 and here the problem is and what
others I had in mind if you try
something like rook to h3 now seemingly
black is lost after the Queen moves
you're gonna win here but not really so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find what was Ali Reza's idea behind
this this move while I give you a couple
of seconds so photos you who were able
to do it congratulations unsporting that
you can give up the Queen like I
mentioned if the rook ever moves you
have route g1 checkmate so for those of
you who just wanna enjoy the show its
Queen captures on f5 and now it doesn't
matter if you trade you always be up
material because whenever white brings
the rook with for example rook captures
then it's just rook to g1 checkmate so
this is what
have in mind however Magnus decided to
block with Bush up to age three and now
both the Queen and the rook are guarding
the bishop so it's not not a problem
here Ali Reza finds rook captures an e2
a very tricky move which now allows
after Queen captures an e2 Bishop
captures on h3 now with the idea of
shifting the bishop back to g4 and now
the problem for a future is that Magnus
just played rook to g1 and it was also
in this position that that other is a
future design the game here if you lose
your design because he missed a very
well he missed a certain replied the
problem is if you trade right away this
for example this rook captures King
captures and now you deliver Queen to g4
check into h1 and there is nothing to be
done here or if instead of Queen you
just go Bishop to g4 you have worked the
f8 with check and now it's a problem
King g7 Queen after you've gotten both
the Queen and the rook out of the way
and now it's just white who's attacking
and the deaths
that's just game over plus you're down
material so not much to be done here and
also best of all is that after this rook
to g1 move if he tried the immediate
Bishop to g4 then do you see what
Carson's winning idea was I even pause
the video while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations
unsporting now a queen sacrifice on
Magnus is part and for those who just
want to enjoy the show it's rook F to g3
and now black loses the bishop that's
all there is there is no move you can
make not to lose the bishop and of
course if the queen is captured then
it's rook the g8 checkmate Brooke the
yeah GA checkmate so really a very
interesting game with both the cross I
mean future having to worry about their
back rank at some point Fallujah was
threatening some rooms you want mate
ideas but cause and now in the end won't
be because of this tactic but future
calculated everything perfectly and
after rook to g1 he just resigned the
game or maybe his time ran out
maybe his time ran out I'm not sure but
whichever it is a good start for Magnus
Carlsen
in round two of of the Magnus
Invitational so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it with the first of
many to come I would like to thank
Phillip Phillip eventual instant
marketing effort Mulder I Joshua knot
and Lauren Mayer for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the magnets
Invitational so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and if you are interested in
joining the tournament the link is in
the description below see you soon